this lonesome wind turbine is located
just off the coast of hook seal on the
North Sea it's a solitary symbol of
Germany's planned shift to renewable
energies and a harbinger of what's to
come a few kilometers out to sea a wind
park this one is called may event ocean
wind and supplies 300 thousand
households a year with electricity but
before a wind park can be built
specially equipped ships have to scan
the sea bed every day weather permitting
a task force heads out on a salvage
vessel to make the North Sea safer
mine's torpedoes and grenades dating
back through both world wars are still
lost in its chilly depths hepa cotton
for clapham skittle well known dumping
sites are enormous they are probably a
million tons of munitions polluting the
North Sea in some areas ammunition was
thrown overboard on the way to the
dumping sites for clubs Kebede from Bob
kawal aircraft will also have dropped
extra weight on the return journeys to
save fuel last up give off in water
which please respond
after the end of the Second World War
when the Allies disarmed the Germans
they disposed of the weapons at sea
they've been there ever since the
saltwater corroding their metal sleeves
so that the explosives seep into the sea
underwater robots like this one can
detect the munitions before they
possibly explode this could happen if an
acid fuse is activated by a chemical
process for example 15 meter radius
check right here so you've got a blows
up here dita Gordon sits in the control
room with his team of technicians and
geophysicists observing the robots
progress it's pretty clear so it should
be more or less I can get off my we
often need to establish the specifics
that means identifying what type of a
grenade it is what kind of an explosive
or mine then we have to decide if it's
transportable can the object be moved
can we take it out of the cable route
we're clearing or do we have to arrange
for a controlled explosion on-site a
diver is dispatched to investigate the
find these experts do dangerous work
defusing bombs that could theoretically
kill them
this object appears to be a Navy mine
the diver has to be scrupulously careful
and avoid sudden movements unsteady
hands could be fatal at this point I'm
Susan Schlichter Berg later the monster
fears disastrous if you're afraid of
explosives then you shouldn't be working
in this field army hadn't recovering a
bomb is only half of the job special
units then need to defuse it small
remnants of potentially dangerous
munitions can also wash up on the coast
the money throwing that all old
munitions are sometimes found by
tourists and hikers on guided tours in
these cases it will be reported by the
tour guide who commended a controlled
explosion is the last resort in the
event that a bomb can't be diffused if
the munitions can't be transported
they're rendered harmless underwater
nature conservationists maintain that
these underwater detonations and danger
marine life such as seals and porpoises
and then cannot go outside and ferb
think of the practice of dynamite
fishing which has thankfully been banned
it killed fish with underwater blasts
marine animals have a lateral line used
to detect movement and vibration in the
surrounding water which also plays a
role in their orientation a blast is
extremely loud and causes pressure that
can kill fish but official few income
the team's commissioned by energy
companies planning the wind parks are
aware of the environmental impact of
their work but they feel that clearing
unexploded ordnance in the North Sea
takes priority it's a threat to shipping
marine life and it's also hampering
Germany's energy transition but the task
force also knows that there's a limit to
what it can do been made through Bobby
clearing all the munitions from the
North Sea is a job that could take
another 10 or 20 years yeah for making
the coastal area completely safe would
cost millions I let alone the whole of
the north sea and Baltic Sea area that
was to guard this place now over a
million tons of munitions were disposed
of in the north and baltic ceased after
the Second World War including highly
toxic chemical weapons a dangerous
inheritance